FOR IF THEY DID, THEY WOULD HAVE
SHUT DOWN THE GEORGE FLOYD
PROTESTS.
HOWIE: JOINING US TO ANALYZE THE
COVERAGE MOLLIE HEMINGWAY,
SENIOR EDITOR.
JEFF JENKINS, FOX NEWS
CORRESPONDENT HERE IN WASHINGTON
AND IN NEW YORK JESSICA TARLOV
ALSO A FOX NEWS CONTRIBUTOR.
MOLLIE, HEADLINES, WHITE HOUSE
IN DENIAL.
THE MEDIA TRYING TO PORTRAY --
MOLLIE: WELL, THEY’VE BEEN
CLEARLY TRYING TO DO THAT FOR
MONTHS NOW.
IN GENERAL THE MEDIA ARE NOT
GOOD AT EXPLAINING CONTEXT OR
NUANCE.
WE LEARNED THAT THE CDC
ESTIMATES THAT 10 TIMES AS MANY
PEOPLE HAVE CORONAVIRUS HAVE
TESTED POSITIVE.
THAT’S WHAT YOU MEAN WHEN YOU
TEST MORE PEOPLE, MORE THAN
2 MILLION AMERICANS HAVE IT.
WE NEED TOE KNOW HOW MANY PEOPLE
ARE BEING HOSPITALIZED, HOW MANY
PEOPLE IN WHICH AGE GROUP HAVE
THIS.
ONE OF THE THINGS OF RECENT
INCREASE OF CASES PREDOMINANTLY
IN YOUNGER AGE GROUPS WHICH ARE
MUCH BETTER SUITED TO HANDLE IT.
IN THIS ENTIRE STORY WE HAVE
SEEN THAT IT’S NOT JUST OLDER
PEOPLE, OLDER PEOPLE IN NURSING
HOME AT RISK.
THIRD AND A HALF OF ALL DEATHS
RELATED TO THIS HAVE BEEN IN
NURSING HOMES.
WE NEED TO HAVE MUCH MORE FOCUS
ON PEOPLE WHO ARE VULNERABLE
THERE AND MUCH LESS ABOUT PEOPLE
WHO ARE ASYMPTOMATIC AT YOUNGER
AGES.
HOWIE: JESSICA, THE GOOD NEWS IS
DEATH RATES ARE WAY DOWN, BUT
MORE THAN 125,000 AMERICANS HAVE
DIED OF THE DISEASE.
DO YOU SEE THE PRESIDENT OF
DOWNPLAYING THE PANDEMIC EVEN
WHEN THE LATEST NUMBERS
REFLECTING SURGE AND THE MEDIA
IMPACT?
JESSICA: HE ABSOLUTELY IS AND I
WOULD ARGUE THAT MIKE PENCE WHEN
HE FINALLY GOT BACK ON
TELEVISION, GIVING THE PRESIDENT
A VICTORY LAP.
EVEN IF IT’S PEOPLE IN MY HIJACK
ARE -- AGE ARE GETTING.
I THINK THE PRESIDENT HELD BACK
AND FORTH, I WAS KIDDING, I
WASN’T KIDDING, HE HUNG KAYLEIGH
MCENANY OUT TO DRY WHEN SHE MADE
A STATEMENT, THE PRESIDENT WAS
JOKING AND THEN HE COMES OUT OH,
I NEVER KID.
WHY ARE YOU JOKING ABOUT PEOPLE
LIVES AND, OF COURSE, THE MEDIA
IS GOING TO COVER THIS WHEN WE
ARE GETTING CRAZY STATS OUT OF
TEXAS, FLORIDA, ARIZONA, PLACES
REOPENED AND ARE HAVING TO SCALE
THAT BACK.
HOWIE: GRIFF, WOULD YOU AGREE
THAT THE MEDIA FOR SEVERAL WEEKS
ESPECIALLY DURING THE PROTESTS
PRETTY MUCH PULLED BACK FROM
THIS STORY AND KIND OF SENT A
SIGNAL THAT IT’S KIND OF OVER AS
A HUGE NATIONAL EMERGENCY?
GRIFF: I WOULD AGREE THAT THEY
PUT THE FRONT AND CENTER THE
VIOLENCE ON THE STREET, CIVIL
UNREST, CATCHING OUR ATTENTION,
OF COURSE, WE’VE HAD NO SHORTAGE
OF GUESTS TALKING WITH LOCAL
LEADERS WHO DID NOT MOVE TO STOP
THE SOCIAL DISTANCING THAT WAS
BEING VIOLATED IN THE
SITUATIONS, BUT YOU KNOW, YOU
RAISE A POINT, WE SAW VICE
PRESIDENT CANCELING TRIP TO
FLORIDA AND ARIZONA BECAUSE THE
CORONAVIRUS CONCERNS AND REALLY
WHAT’S MOST IMPORTANT ABOUT THIS
DISCUSSION I THINK IS THAT THE
VIRUS IS THE ONLY APOLITICAL
PLAYER IN ALL OF THIS, AND THE
DATA MATTERS SIGNIFICANTLY.
I INTERVIEWED YESTERDAY A REAL
SMART EXPERT WHO SAYS, LOOK, IF
YOU GET HOSPITALIZED IN FLORIDA,
YOU ARE 85 YEAR’S OLD, YOU HAVE
CHANCE OF DYING --
>> HOWIE: THE PRESS IS GROWING
TIRED OF THE STORY AND
REPETITIVE AND DEPRESSING.
MOLLIE, WHAT DO YOU THINK OF
JESSICA’S POINT ABOUT TESTING,
SOME PUBLIC HEALTH EXPERTS SAY
IT’S BEYOND INCREASE TESTING,
IT’S MORE POSITIVE RATES WHEN
YOU TESTS.
MOLLIE: IT’S IMPORTANT THAT WE
CHANGE AS NEW FACTS COME ON THE
GROUND.
WHEN THIS BEGAN IT WAS EXTREMELY
SCARY AND WE WERE SEEING CERTAIN
RESULTS IN TESTING RATES AND NOW
WE HAVE A MUCH LOWER CASE
FATALITY RATE.
WE HAVE A MUCH GREATER SURVIVAL
RATE, WE HAVE LEARNED SO MUCH
MORE ABOUT HOW IT AFFECTS PEOPLE
IN DIFFERENT AGE GROUPS AND
THAT’S WHERE I’M NOT SEEING THE
MEDIA COVERAGE CHANGE.
THEY ARE STILL ACTING LIKE WE
DON’T KNOW ANYTHING ABOUT THIS
AND WE NEED TO HAVE THE SAME
LEVEL OF FEAR.
THERE’S CERTAIN AMOUNT OF
REASONABLE FEAR, 5, 10, 20 TIMES
AS SCARY AS IT ACTUALLY IS
THAT’S NOT HELPFUL.
WE NEED TO HAVE BETTER RISK
COMPARISONS, THERE’S RISK WITH
EVERYTHING THAT WE DO NO LIFE.
THE RISK PEOPLE BELOW A CERTAIN
AGE GROUP IS VERY SMALL.
THE RISK OF PEOPLE IN NURSING
HOMES, 1 IN 6, JUST UNDER ONE
AND 6 PEOPLE IN NEW JERSEY IN
NURSING HOMES DIED.
THEY ARE TRYING TO MAKE IT SOUND
GENERAL WHEN IT’S A FOCUSED
PROBLEM AND ONE THAT WE ARE NOT
PAYING ENOUGH ATTENTION TO THERE
AND WE ARE ACTING LIKE IT’S THE
SAME LEVEL OF RISK FOR PEOPLE
WHO ARE AT SCHOOL OR WHAT NOT
WHEN THEY ACTUALLY ARE NOT
SPREADERS OF THE SAME, IN ANY
WAY THE SAME.
HOWIE: JESSICA, LET ME GET YOUR
RESPONSE TO THAT.
PRESIDENT TRUMP’S OWN MENTIONS
OF COVID-19 DECLINE BY
TWO-THIRDS FROM APRIL TO EARLY
JUNE AND I THINK THE MEDIA TAKE
A LOT OF CUES FROM POTUS.
JESSICA: YES, ABSOLUTELY, HE
DOMINATES ON CHOSEN MEDIA FORM
FOR POLITICS, SO EVERYONE WILL
HAVE TO FOLLOW HIS LEAD THERE.
WE KNOW WHY THE PRESIDENT
DOESN’T WANT TO TALK ABOUT IT.
HE HAS A REELECTION CAMPAIGN TO
RUN AND HE WANTS TO BE LAW AND
ORDER CANDIDATE AND HE DOESN’T
WANT TO HAVE SORRY 125,000
AMERICANS DIED AND I WAS OUT FOR
LUNCH WHEN I SHOULD HAVE BEEN
PREPARING ABOUT THIS.
A LOT ABOUT THE OP-ED THAT JOE
BIDEN WROTE SAYING THAT
PRESIDENT TRUMP IS THE WORST
PERSON TO BE IN CHARGE IF WE ARE
GOING TO HAVE A HEALTH PANDEMIC.
LOOK AT THAT, BIDEN WAS RIGHT.
BIDEN IS UP ABOUT 10 POINTS
RIGHT NOW.
THE NUMBER 1 ISSUE IN THE
ELECTION IN THE LAST TWO CYCLES
WILL BE HEALTH CARE, IT WOULD BE
THE NUMBER ONE 1 ISSUE.
THE PRESIDENT CAN GO TO BORDER
WALL ALL THAT HE WANTS, HE CAN
TALK ABOUT BLACK LIVES MATTER IS
A TERRORIST ORGANIZATION, ET
CETERA, BUT WHEN PEOPLE ARE
DYING WHETHER THEY ARE 85 OR
WHETHER IT’S 30, 35-YEAR-OLDS
THAT ARE GETTING SICK AND DON’T
KNOW THE LONG-TERM IMPLICATIONS,
WE HEARD IT CAN HAVE LUNG --
LONGER-TERM CAPACITY
IMPLICATIONS.
HOWIE: THE MEDIA’S COVERAGE HAVE
BEEN SPOTTY AT TIMES.
GRIFF, SO HAPPENS THAT MIKE
PENCE SHARED THE FIRST
CORONAVIRUS TASK FORCE HEARING
IN 2 MONTHS, WASN’T AT THE WHITE
HOUSE, IT WAS AT HHS.
THE PRESIDENT DID NOT APPEAR.
PENCE SAID WE MADE PROGRESS.
FAUCI WHO REPORT SIDELINED ON TV
URGED CAUTION.
DID THE PRESIDENT ALL OF THIS
CANCELING THE DAILY SHOW, THE
CORONAVIRUS TASK FORCE KIND OF
DAMPEN THE MEDIA’S INTEREST?
GRIFF: POSSIBLY, TO THE POINT,
GOOD ONE THAT YOU RAISE BECAUSE
MAYBE THEY SHOULD BRING IT BACK
ON A DAILY BASIS.
AS JESSICA POINTS OUT
ACCURATELY, WHERE THIS VIRUS AND
HOW THE COUNTRY HANDLED 130 SO
DAYS FROM NOW WILL DEPEND WHO
WINS THE WHITE HOUSE AND IT
APPEARED EVEN THOUGH THE
PRESIDENT AT ONE POINT WANTED TO
DO ENTIRELY WITH THE BRIEFING,
THERE WAS A HUNGER AND CONSENT
OF HUNGER FOR THE INFORMATION,
FOR DATA, FOR THE
RECOMMENDATIONS AND REALLY NOW
IN THE ABSENCE OF THOSE
BRIEFINGS WE ARE GETTING, YOU
KNOW, NATIONAL DEBATES OVER
WHETHER YOU SHOULD WEAR A MASK
OR NOT.
I THINK HE WOULD DO HIMSELF A
FAVOR OF BRINGING IT BACK FULL
FORCE.
HOWIE: ALL RIGHT, WE ARE TIGHT
ON TIME.
WHAT IS THE WHOLE DEBATE ABOUT
WHETHER PEOPLE SHOULD WEAR A
MASK IF THEY GO TO PUBLIC OR
CROWDED PLACES, WHY HAS IT
BECOME POLITICIZED, IS IT IN
PART BECAUSE PRESIDENT TRUMP IS
NOT PUBLICLY EMBRACED WEAR
AUGUST MASK HIMSELF AND HASN’T
EMBRACED THE RECOMMENDATION AND
GOVERNORS MAYORS ARE WEARING,
WHY DO YOU THINK IT’S BECOME
POLITICIZED?
MOLLIE: WE MIGHT BEGIN AT THE
BEGINNING WHERE WE WERE TOLD
THAT MASKS DID NOTHING TO
PREVENT THE SPREAD OF
CORONAVIRUS.
WE HAD THESE EXPERTS EVEN IN THE
TRUMP ADMINISTRATION WHO ARE
SAYING THAT THEY WEREN’T
NECESSARY, THEN THEY SAY THEY.
I THINK IT’S AN ISSUE OF NUANCE,
PEOPLE ARE UNABLE TO UNDERSTAND
THAT THERE MIGHT BE TIMES YOU’RE
WEARING A MECHANIC AND TIMES
THAT YOU AREN’T.
ON BOTH EXTREMES YOU HAVE PEOPLE
THAT YOU HAVE TO WEAR IT AT ALL
TIMES OR NOT, IN GENERAL, WE
NEED MUCH MORE ACCURATE COVERAGE
OF ACTUAL RISKS BEING OUTSIDE,
EXERCISING, FOR INSTANCE, BEING
MORE THAN 6 FEET APART YOU DON’T
NEED TO WEAR A MASK.
HOWIE: JESSICA, THE SAME
QUESTION ABOUT THE SHUTDOWNS AND
WHETHER THEY WERE TOO QUICKLY
AND TO COME BACK SEEMS TO BECOME
PARTISAN ISSUE FOR THE MEDIA.
JESSICA: YEAH, ABSOLUTELY, BUT
THERE WERE BIG MISTAKES THAT
PEOPLE IN MY OWN PARTY HAVE
MADE.
ARTICLES IN LEFT-WING
PUBLICATIONS SAID THAT IF CUOMO
HAD SHUT DOWN NEW YORK A WEEK
EARLIER AND TAKEN THE EXAMPLE
THAT THEY DID IN SAN FRANCISCO
WE COULD HAVE SAVED LIVES AND
NOT HAVE THE NURSING HOME
SCANDAL, THAT’S NEW YORK AND NEW
JERSEY WHERE IT’S BEEN THE WORST
AND THOSE ARE BLUE STATES BUT TO
MOLLIE’S POINT BY THE PRESIDENT,
HE HAS TO LEAD BY EXAMPLE, THE
SURGEON GENERAL SAYS WEAR A
MASK, THE PRESIDENT SHOULD WEAR
A MASK.
HOWIE: YOU MAY BE WATCHING IN A
STATE WHERE CORONAVIRUS IS NOT
SURGING BUT FLORIDA AND TEXAS
THEY SHUT DOWN BARS, BETTER
SITUATION IN NEW YORK AND DC
WHERE MOST OF THE MEDIA ARE